breathing's from podcast Ville the
church are what's happening now is
brought to you by my [ __ ] favorite me
undies listen you heard me talk about
them before you know they're fun they're
comfy on these that feel as good as they
look to those who haven't tried them yet
listen up you can get an incredible pair
underwear sent to your door with me
undies meaning no more hunting around
for the perfect pair the crowded store
and eventually set settling for good
enough some white [ __ ] things or some
loose things me and these are the best
underwear out there since I've been
doing a podcast they've been work on me
like that that's the only underwear I
wear done I got rid of the white ones
the boxes everything you know why
because of the material the material I
don't even know it don't matter
it keeps the nutsack it keeps the
muffler everything nice and moist and
that's the most important thing nice and
dry nice and dry what do you mean nice
and moist John or 1b you know nice and
dry that's what I'm saying
go to me undies right now go to me
undies calm right now and what I'm gonna
do is get you ton 20% off your first
pair free shipping and 100% money-back
satisfaction guarantee right now go to
me undies doc tom slash Joey that's my
undies calm slash Joey's I don't explain
some to you I got some great underwear
but do you know that 66% of men lose
their hair by the age of 35 thing is
when you start to notice hair loss it's
too late it's easier to keep the hair
you have then to replace their hey
you've lost now you're looking at me go
enjoy what the [ __ ] do you know about
that let me explain something I know I
got the Elvis hairdo right now at 55 but
I grew up with a guy that didn't have
had and it killed him I watched him he
ended up robbing a gas station when he
was like 40 part of it was they had
problem he had because he did the plugs
he was spray paint in his head he did
everything I wish I wish for hims calm a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men was around then
because my man wouldn't have gone crazy
understand me listen no waiting room no
awkward doctor visits save hours by
going to for hems calm that's fo r hims
dot-com order now and the church family
gets a trial month of hymns for just
five hours today right now why supplies
less go to the website for full details
this will cause hundreds if you went to
a doctor or a pharmacy so go to four
hymns dot-com / Joey that's four hymns
doc times last Joey again that's for
hymns dot-com / Joey keep everything
together keep the hair on your head keep
doctor and kick this mealy it's a
beautiful [ __ ] thing to be alive if
you haven't seen Steven Tyler on the Joe
Rogan podcast you slippin out I learned
a lot my guest today is the beautiful my
man mr. Donovan [ __ ] Patton hey and
the christ-killers here hello ready to
rock but the most important thing is I
love this guy he's the most interesting
I met in LA the last three or four years
like at first I saw him alone like this
guy's just a [ __ ] nice sweetheart of
a guy and then he moved to New York for
a while we do the show I got them he
came out and we had a driver but again
I'm with this guy's the real [ __ ]
deal like he knew his hand around the
city he knew where he was going and you
were raised here I'm wasn't raised
anywhere I'm a military brat so I'm like
I was born in Guam like I don't have a
hometown I lived in New York for about
16 years I was born in Guam we moved to
Colorado Springs and Aurora and Denver
my that's where my mom's from my
father's from Utah and then and then
they divorced when my mom got remarried
and moved to Germany moved to Vegas
lived in Vegas for three years moved to
Napa California but then I ended up
going to this boarding school in
Michigan and then I moved to New York
after that well Jersey City and then New
York City after that so I I bounced
around and then I'm you know when we
moved here moved back to New York they
moved here again can't stay in one place
I haven't lived in the same house for
more than two years for my entire life
oh my god it's kind of crazy that sucks
are you happy you're pretty much settled
down down yeah I think we're done for a
while we got kids now so it's like we
got a we got a try at least to stay in
one spot for them for a little bit I
think
no tell these [ __ ] yeah well
you did four years
that was the most interesting that thing
ever when my wife was telling me right
I had no [ __ ] ideas she filmed me and
she knows I don't know dick about dick I
did Blue's Clues for for eight years I
did a show called Blue's Clues I took
over for the the first hostess dude
Steve and then again and how old was
Steve when you took over I don't know he
was in his 20s I want to say I was like
21 22 when I got that job so and how'd
you get the job fresh from an agent
called James ya know and they all they
saw you somewhere
ya know it was it was just a regular
audition I was I was doing plays in New
York and waiting tables and it was like
the one that worked that was up I was up
for Blue's Clues and Blair Witch two at
the same time and I remember being
really psyched about my Blair Witch
audition because I got to make out in
that audition and uh yeah it was like a
weird thing like you know the you know I
don't know I got to meet the director
this guy Joe Berlin juror who's done
some amazing documentaries he did a you
know some kind of monster and and I
don't know some some pretty heavy stuff
and but I got to meet him and I used to
work at this video store where I would
deliver skate on a skateboard delivering
videos around they got pretty sight it
was like silly so I got to meet this
dude whose movies I loved and then and
then on the whole flipside of that
completely opposite to all of that I was
up for this show Blue's Clues that I
didn't know a whole lot about and so you
know that's that's the one I landed and
I'm like it was something I never
intended to do kids TV ever nobody does
yeah nobody wakes up one morning they're
you know man I'm gonna [ __ ] be a
Disney actor some people do and and when
you see it you see it they yeah I showed
a Disney show it's the world of kid
acting yeah it's [ __ ] nuts
well with kids it's it's different you
know what kids it gets to be like a
whole weird thing you know because half
the time you're like dude are these kids
actually into it like you know III had
the opportunity to meet a couple of kids
doing interstitials they're basically
just commercials and stuff like that and
I met these two kids McKenzie and Zoe I
don't know their last names and I
probably wouldn't say those things but
but they were loving it like most of the
other kids that were on set that day you
can tell it was just like a little bit
of work for them and their parents are
really getting them into it these kids
you
was in like around the South Street
Seaport in New York in February and it
dumped about a foot of snow that whole
day and we were sitting outside shooting
part of it and they didn't care so some
kids loved it
it's great you have children though I do
yeah I got a I call them frankincense
and myrrh in the public know that they
came home my daughter's done some
voiceover auditions and stuff like that
like my voiceover agent since her
audition she does a great job - yeah she
probably does yeah she's good
they do it right off the natural they
don't need an acting coach not they
reader how they see it
now what about if she told you she wanna
do in front of a camera
I mean she's talked to me about that a
little bit I'd be okay with it as long
if she if it's what she wants like I
just don't want to be me pushing that
agenda on her I think that's where the
problem is is that some unrealized dream
of a parent I mean I don't know isn't
that with a lot of things I bought ball
could be whatever I never you know I
don't know you never think of acting and
then I came out here and I started
acting the first couple things I did I
didn't know this deck I was just happy
to be there yeah and then I started
landing roles that involve kids hmm and
I'm a hands off kids guy like you know
at that time I was probably dating Terry
and I was going through my old [ __ ] with
my daughter oldest daughter so I was
like I ain't talking to [ __ ] kids
kids the last night I booked it but
everyone saw why you have to talk to him
you know you have to talk to him there
you're in a scene with her more and I
get to see their parents yeah and I get
to see the story you know after a few
days and you were a kid on set for one
day you really don't see [ __ ] it's after
a few days you know first off week you
can only shoot like four hours right
yeah it's like weird that forget they
have school yeah you enough there's
teachers on set and a dog I like I've
done I did a string of movies with kids
and the teacher on that set was creepy
yeah really yeah because this this this
production company was cheap so they
always hired the
to do things and your teacher they had I
could tell he was like a molester I
could tell like I was looking at him
going all this [ __ ] I had my eye
on him the whole [ __ ] time but then I
did TV shows with kids yeah and that's
when I noticed the creepiness well you
told me a story about like an audition
you went on right here mentor with that
woman on the floor seven years ago right
there were they audition people in
Studio City for commercials yeah yeah
building I think it's next to all can
Harry's or something sure it's a big big
[ __ ] place where was a day like this
where it was drizzling out going to rain
back to drizzle and we have yet a park a
block away and [ __ ] dry like walk a
block like it was packed this isn't the
height of the audition stage you were
going to to commercial audition today
like you would believe in one and they'd
be hitting you up to drive to Bundy
because they're looking for a hand model
you know [ __ ] like that 5:45 this is
crazy Lee this is pre 2005 where you
went out a ton in this town a ton have
you had a heartbeat and I went to this
[ __ ] place it was raining out and I
walked in and people in this sardine
yeah like this Ardennes but this little
Asian girl beautiful you know that would
be eight nine you could tell the kids
gonna be a [ __ ] star yeah and I'm no
problem with that
the problem I had is that she had a head
shots like 22 of them laid on the floor
and she was taking this much area room
all the people were standing outside and
the mother didn't say nothing was it all
the same picture it was all off
different her girlfriends were picking
up pictures I think it creeps out the
kid a little bit if the kid is not
prepared for that situation if you take
that kid past a certain level well I
mean it's you're asking them to do an
adult job it's weird it's a job you know
it's it's a strange thing you know it's
it's doing plays or something can be fun
if you're doing them at school or
something like I don't know right but I
started wanted to act in June
hi but that's a world away from from I
don't know some of it were young
something that we've been talking about
a lot recently is how what this town can
do to you and how like how some adults
go crazy here
I can't imagine growing up from that and
being 8 or being 4 and then from your
you literally your entire life people
are kissing you're out doing whatever
and like maybe that's why there's a lot
of child actors who have issues because
maybe at twenty-something then I'll get
some gigs and they're used to people
being certain ways they you know you've
seen it we've had a few [ __ ] crazy
people in this [ __ ] place that yeah
they were child actors and you see the
difference if it does something to you I
don't know if I want mercy in that world
right on I just don't even I don't even
like it you don't even like the parents
like where I went to breakfast is more
there's women that live right there
[ __ ] Mariah Carey because their
husbands a writer on a show and write
behavior is unacceptable in my world
like how they drive around Studio City
how they pull up they double sideways
yeah they pull up and a double par and
they just don't give a [ __ ] and at the
end of the day your husband is just like
me with just a piece of meat sure I
don't know why the [ __ ] you driving
around acting like you know the town
drove that lady crazy she started
believing the hype but the parties and
[ __ ] like that I can't imagine what it
does to a young mind but my point this
whole [ __ ] thing was there was one
show I did where I record and that was
the first time I saw the creepiness of
it's like the kids are puppets for the
parents now I'm not saying well hmm I'm
not saying all of them I'm just saying
like all the five kids on that
particular show two of the parents were
beyond creepy but then I did a guest
star in another kids show and I had a
great experience the director was
[ __ ] phenomenal yeah what how he
worked with those kids was brilliant
the only thing I found weird on that set
was the Paris that one was the aw that
was this was the pinnacle of the biggest
kid company which is Disney this was
some of their hit shows and I talked to
the one mom press the wall on shoot days
you did the mom's gonna shoot right
you think the moms are gonna shoot the
moms all have fake tits mom had
liposuction I mean they bleed they're
hot what people call milfs you know sure
whatever hot white women I don't [ __ ]
know like these are milfs do you think
they dress up to try to get discovered
for the show I don't know how you don't
understand it but then you talk to them
and they'll tell you different
situations like where you from the
accident scenes I told the girl North
Bergen New Jersey oh my god
we live in Weehawken yeah I think oh
really is what we're Ridgely I thought
you guys were from the south carolina's
you know were really for South Carolina
but because of his acting we want to be
close to the city so we rent the city
right over the bridge yeah they rent
this right no it's like 2,000 a month
like a where's your husband she's like
my husband's back working we're out here
while he's [ __ ] busting his ass and
whatever town isn't was his construction
company sending money up so Timmy could
have his dream of acting so the kid was
doing like plays in New York so the mom
would get up with the kid and just haul
off to different cities he was telling
me the story was like being like huh
like like your daughter second sophomore
only for acting yeah but you see it like
the parent was maybe a failed actor or
maybe never even fulfill that dream
so they pushed that dream on their child
and you see it yeah that's I mean I
don't want to tell anybody what to do
ever like I kind of lived my entire life
to try to never ever tell anybody what
to do and that's weird as a parent
because it's sort of your job to help
try to get them to be a fully functional
adult at some point but but yeah it
crosses a total line whenever you you're
putting your dream
essentially on to another person they
got a girl and be their own person I
don't know it's not like I anytime I
feel like I say anything like I know
what I'm talking about one who's the
parent thing my kids are young I got a
skip to the end of the book I feel knows
how that's gonna turn out listen better
when people when I think to myself about
my parent I just shake my head yeah I
can't believe I'm a parent I can't have
to all the things I'm the craziness I've
lived now I gotta tell some child how to
[ __ ] live I'm in the same boat as you
I guide her a little bit you know I want
him to learn how to protect this out
yeah I want her to she doing jujitsu
yeah like she doesn't even comprehend
the today's our last karate class nice
at the school okay but she doesn't get
it guys
so I can't push it on her yeah he's a
sweet kid I can't change her [ __ ] DNA
she really really really is a sweet kid
yeah and I have seen her lately
wait the event men she's we went then
hmm the kids wouldn't share with her the
black board she thought him bucket I'll
sit here and wait until whatever was
nice or whatever and then one of the
kids left and she picked up chocolate
she went to a little corner and she
don't bother nobody you know it's gonna
it's gonna shock her when a kid does
something mean to her I see how she
reacts she's still mad at kids from two
years ago
hahaha oh yeah she did she only run as a
kid at her school now that keeps busting
her ball everybody's balls he's become a
real pain he has I feel bad for the
parents right I feel bad for the parents
but you know you talk to Mercy she
[ __ ] gets pissed off about ballet
there's another ballbuster girl in
ballet and she's gotta tell the girl
like knock it off stop it do you know
what she stands up for herself you know
it's like a little bit but I could tell
she feels bad ah she feels about later
on I asked it's just too much she said
to me in a funny way that I was like
okay this is my daughter yeah you know
this is my daughter she gets it I
understands you don't like people
breathe another
she don't like people moving around too
much like mice do blow hey the people
moved around a lot
around me like I don't like I stay
physically around here be come over sit
[ __ ] still you got to go to the
bathroom I don't want no dancing oh look
at that windows I don't want no [ __ ]
nothing all right
it makes me nervous all that [ __ ] mate
when I'm home with my daughter she's
running around it makes me [ __ ]
nervous dollar fifteen times the same
that goddamn playground this is a little
point you can't relax from there around
well it's all I level right now too
right yeah she's gonna bust her eyes oh
well she comes into the room the office
and [ __ ] jumps around and you know
then the office I got a watch because I
got everything in that office I got
knees I got this is I got a stapler you
know I got vitamins like this saw yeah
big last thing in the corner yeah that's
a big thing of your hands like Tommy you
got a pineapple and [ __ ] but it's I
don't know I don't you wanna tell her I
do saying I don't want to understand
what I do if she's gonna have to
experience that at some point though
right what's that like she's gonna be
able to find it or you know like like
cuz your stuffs all online
yeah what does that change how you I
mean I don't I guess I probably know
will change becomes on my mouth it
scares me a little bit that I mention
she's gonna find that stuff but you're
gonna have the benefit of hat by talking
to her beforehand you know like you talk
to her every day oh you know so like
she's not gonna I don't know grow up to
me between you and Terry I feel like
she's gonna grow up and know how to just
stand up for herself like you're saying
yeah you know you have to you have to
have your child stand up themselves I
don't want I don't want her to know
about to stand up early uh yeah because
I don't want her going into class and
acting like the [ __ ] ask the class
clown that means the world to me that
she doesn't go in there and thinks
because I do what I do she could act
like a [ __ ] clown in class at any
acceptable
yeah that's why I want to take away from
that I mean if she comes to me one day
and she doesn't talk to me about saying
that I haven't talked to her about it
yeah I have no choice but I gotta be
honest oh yeah I've seen daughters of
climax that are trying to do stand-up
and all that stuff and it's a disaster
it comes from a different place be comes
from a different place because as a
comic maybe and that talking about this
in general maybe this is why I take
mercy so seriously because as I see I've
seen the daughters of famous comics hmm
the dads are on the road that that's
missed a few birthdays cuz they're on
the road doing the show yeah you know I
want to do that but on the other hand I
don't want to do that I just wanna be a
regular that yeah I mean it's yeah it's
such a mix but at the same time I I
wrestled with that as a parent a lot too
just in terms of how much you want to be
there and be involved and because my
schedules irregular there's sort of this
this idea that my wife and I have we
both have irregular schedules that we
should be there for all of it can't miss
any of it but then I also think they're
gonna have to grow up and you're gonna
have they're gonna grow up watching you
and and don't they want to see you doing
something essentially like you know
they're gonna have to want to go see you
like a capable person my wife always
when my kids were younger she would have
to she's a photographer so she would
leave town every now and again and she
got really upset about everything she
missed and I said they're gonna grow up
and they're gonna see this woman who
built her own business they're gonna see
this woman who basically is like fully
capable completely professional and like
knows what she's doing that's the model
that they're gonna have so I mean I mean
who knows like he got a beat you can't
be gone all the time but I feel like
everything about parenting
I'm completely split in half about me
too because you don't I mean we're not
gonna know until they're 2037 like I was
like if what we did what I've been
around so many people that have been
broken including myself hmm and I know
where the gaps were yeah you know I know
the gaps were when I first turned when I
was first
well that was 27 years old I wasn't
ready for I wasn't even ready for
lifetime my parenting parenting was
about money hmm
what you could buy the child and [ __ ]
like that right sort of how my childhood
was no way I like the other style of
parenting
you're a parent thing is watching TV
with your kid for it out help them with
down work taking that walk with them
tremendous yeah being at their [ __ ]
events you know letting them know you're
there when they look to a certain place
they know you're there you know they're
always in comfort you know things are
gonna pop up yeah things pop up things
pop up but I wanna be like this year mr.
World Fair decided to okay I missed the
World Fair that sucks dick that's her
day I can't be this so next year I gotta
look around that date and not book at
that date hmm
and these little things that I'll
continue to [ __ ] do while I'm doing
comedy because I know how much my
presence is important if not she's gonna
be searching for those answers economy
clubs to you well don't you think I mean
obviously your presence is very
important but I I grew up with some
people who whose parents were always
there to a point where when they get to
be 23 when they're moving out of college
or even when they get to just college
they kind of lose it
because they don't know how to do
laundry they don't know how to just
survive by themselves a little bit I
made my kid change a tire the other day
I got mercy mercy cooks she brings the
laundry to the thing hmm
she does all that [ __ ] and as she gets
older that's listen man like I say a
thousand times so that was 12 in the
summers I would get up and my mom would
give me a mission and that mission
wasn't a pleasant mission those missions
taught me how to pay bills I she would
send me to pay the mortgage hello and
walk right like walk like this gonna
take you four hours you had to go to the
bank yeah
and then take the cash well she paid me
with you know she paid everything with
cash there was no checkbook checkbook
for her business so just the test of
carrying a thousand dollars in my pocket
of 12 just the test of me and why let
somebody you know when I was five in New
York this same chain my mom would put on
your neck
who puts a chain like this now on the
kids neck when you're five in New York
City is that when you work you know but
it was the same chain with lazurite
diamonds in it I was too cheap I didn't
want to spring for the diamonds and then
I watch it and my mom would say no let
nobody touch that so you sent me with a
thousand dollars I would have come back
with a wheelbarrow full of big league
chew
yeah whatever the mortgage was want
someone that will pay it then the next
week I had to go pay the phone bill and
the electric bill by the time I was 10
by the time I got out of Catholic school
like when I had my little B for Catholic
school and I came home they were not
very happy yeah they were like by the
way life has changed here hmm the time
zones the hours have changed here
because we'll ever retired Pepe and
seeing oh the the birthday bartender or
something my mom has split shift in the
morning so she's like you only doesn't
know hey you guys come up to the bar
that's right one number two you want to
wear this clothes you better start
washing [ __ ] yeah cuz I don't do the
laundry till Sunday night because of my
schedule so there's something you wanna
wear you better learn how to wash it and
right then and there went downstairs and
she showed me how to do the washing
machine the whites the colors what water
temperature the softener bah-bah-bah
just like when little soprano moved in
with Tony there he goes just write down
what you want huh good go to the
supermarket i reimburse you when I moved
back from Catholic school it was a
different world yeah when I went into
the sixth grade it was it was all my own
ironing I had to do my own ironing like
I found when I closed during the week
with creases in the pants I had to set
up a [ __ ] ironing board and I was
like yeah she didn't [ __ ] around she was
like you got thrown
Catholic school now you got to carry
that load on your SATs
and I'd never forget that first summer
like my friends were going swimming I
didn't I couldn't goes from know how to
go pay the mortgage and she would say
the quicker you leave to get there you
get back to your or be hmm and then I
watch the sand for the summer red fox
and it's a job do it and get it over
with I'm like he's right so I would get
up like it's 6:00
hmm and start walking up the hill at
6:00 get a ride from somebody's dad and
I'd be there at 8:00 when the bank
opened I'd pay the mortgage and now I'd
walk back to on the [ __ ] Hill and I
figured out how to do it you know hey
bro you go up over the hill in the
daytime and I go away the 60th and
Bergen like perfect trying you off on
six online and how I walk I walk from
60th you burn right I think the bank was
on 56th Rita so then I walk home from
5060 then I cut through the cemetery and
I'll [ __ ] kind of that hour of my
time the other ones were easy the phone
bill was easy and I leave mind going
there cuz it was next to a diner that
made a BLT that rock you [ __ ] world
and their cream a turkey soup that would
put hair on your balls even in the
summertime you were an 8 year old
getting a BLT in the diner Byers 1111
hysterical no well that would come home
on the weekends I would walk to the
four-star after a Bruce Lee movie at
9:00 I was 9 got a little Bruce Lee died
when I was 10 guys yeah well so all
those movies I watched at 7 8 and I
would go too late viewing of Chinese
connection so I wouldn't get back to the
bar till 1:15 do you actually think I
would let my eight-year-old daughter
know go to the movie theater and the
movie theater was let's say we're
talking about uh-oh what deserve be no
I'm Lancashire give me the little animal
center or whatever like Emily Emily okay
my mother hated the movie theater in
contrast to the bar like if I went down
towards Hollywood
instead of going north to Sunland
I would probably have to walk down to
the church what's that Church past
Moorpark
oh we're that thing for your surrey
school Church that whole thing no right
by Ernie's tacos yeah right by Moorpark
they have like uh what's that Street I
guess more parking Colfax or not more
bargain Lankershim like parking
Lancashire they have the [ __ ] coffee
shop oh yeah it's in Charles Borromeo
coffee coffee bean they got a gas
station across the street they got a
McDonald's dad all day
mmm close by hey I hate that I know this
but the McDonald's is on Riverside
Riverside I know that Zoo sure would be
Riverside to the Laemmle my mother's bar
and I'm like okay and I would walk back
at 1:00 in the morning
[ __ ] would I let MERS Wow go to that
movie theater I don't think so not that
long of a walk but at 1:00 in the
morning for a mural that's a long
[ __ ] long ya know for eight-year-olds
five of us nine-year-old the
twelve-year-old
and be a gang of us that's the other
thing well that gets better and just in
terms of like you know the numbers it
was except for he's like the stupidity
level of what could possibly happen
between all you totally raises we would
leave that we go to a Bruce Lee movie
you leave there [ __ ] ready establish
our fighting each other down the yeah
we're talking about [ __ ] yelling and
screaming and fighting at each other
what made you get into acting at what
age did you I I got in it like eighth
grade I took an acting class in eighth
grade cuz my brother had done one what
was the report this was in Vegas okay
and before that I just I wanted to be a
soccer player like I had no thoughts
other than maybe I'm gonna go to college
someday I want to play soccer through
high school hopefully in college
something I didn't know idea like I
don't know we moved around I knew I
didn't want to go in the military I knew
that much I would get suspended from
school before that when we were living
in Germany and I would have to go like
in where my my stepdad was working and
it was like the most boring experience
known to humankind and some of the
people he worked with which is crazy so
I was like I don't want to go in the Air
Force I know that much and then so I
took this acting class and um I don't
know cuz there were girls in the class
basically that was that was it like you
know my brother would tell me
the stories that they had to read the
year before and I was like and there's
girls from class
so like you know in Vegas it was a
strange social hierarchy at that time
because the athletes like weren't
necessarily at the top of the food chain
or whatever like it was a strange like
it was almost like um um like real bad
boys were the coolest kids and all the
girls were like but but I I went into
that class nothing that I did ever
mattered like I've you know because it's
like those two guys in that class and
then the rest is all girls and so that
part of it was happy and yeah I did this
this little one-act play and and then
somebody dropped out of the other one
they had me do that one so next thing
you know I'm doing two of them and I
knew right away that first night when we
were performing just as soon as it was
done I got this crazy rush and I
remember I can still see it in my head
just like looking out at the audience
and this is tiny little theater and a
junior high well my teacher was this
woman Mary Johnson she also taught me
Spanish and she just she really
encouraged me and she was super
supportive and I I knew right then like
I kind of like I was playing soccer with
like the high school team they're like
summer team I wasn't super great but I
was like good enough I I used my left
foot so like a you know they they had a
place for me sensually and that
everything changed like after that one
night I knew exactly what I wanted to do
and I ended up going to this summer camp
called interlaken arts camp where i
eventually finished high school and i
just got woken up to a whole other world
of stuff just in terms of people who
thought artistically and most of the
people at that summer camp were
musicians but but yeah so it's like
eighth grade I kind of I was lucky in
that sense that I knew what I wanted to
do at that age I didn't have to go find
that in college or whatever I didn't go
to college I didn't get myself the
option I graduated high school and I
moved to New York City and I went to an
acting school did it ever get myself no
no second option did it ever waive our
duty over for like a year where you're
like oh maybe I'll go do construction or
maybe I will go to college or or the way
you committed the whole no I always just
knew that's what I was gonna do and I
had jobs just to you know cuz I had to
survive it was like new periods where I
was living on people's couches there
were there were periods where I was like
you're talking about long walks like in
New York I would I would have to go I
got fired from every single job I would
wait tables at all kinds of places and I
get fired and sometimes rehired because
I was an irresponsible employee like I'd
show up late all the time I try to like
schedule an audition or whatever but
when I was there I'd work hard I try I
was never really that good of a waiter I
got fired from Starbucks from Barnes &
Noble I got fired from Oliver grazie
when you realize what we couldn't do
yeah like I couldn't do [ __ ] I tried
everything but I couldn't do [ __ ] and I
didn't want to do it hmm
like once I got my mind but I could do
comedy that was it I was bright I would
try doing jobs and there was just a
waste of time like once you want to do
something yeah anything and you try to
say so it's just a job Joey it's just a
job to get me to that next level
until I can make money doing that anyway
I'm gonna try to do this do you remember
the first time like the very first time
you ever went up in front of people
yeah doing comedy oh yeah first time I
ever do a thing was freshman year I
joined the intro of Performing Arts huh
and it was a split-level class like
three credits but after you did
something else I can't remember what the
other thing was guys hmm it was my first
introduction to improv I don't know why
I took it
don't ask me why I didn't like him
probably like I said my life even though
we said his height with Belushi oh yeah
I still wasn't into that I liked
stand-up comedy but it was so far off
the radar so far off the radar that that
it wasn't even a thought process at that
time it was when I went into my freshman
year probably it was still Freddie
Prinze Richard Pryor Negroes Carl and
David Brenner that was your you know you
know Don Rickles hmm you knew Don the
guy that had the really funny guy that
white dude that spot was clean he's
[ __ ] hilarious
you knew him a whole lot new hard rock
you aren't ya [ __ ] Bob Newhart our
great
then yeah steve warwood I still have the
button-down mine I have a CD and yeah
it's [ __ ] Bob knew I was the [ __ ] and
you gotta I Lenny Bruce came later once
I really started looking at the Kombi it
came later but the first thing I ever
did for that teacher she was a little
lesbian chick she made me get up and
sing shattered by the Rolling Stone with
all the [ __ ] do bees and everything yeah
it was the hottest [ __ ] song on the
radio at that time and it was my
freshman year some way that she made me
go up there that was like wow I could
not believe but I had already in the
sixth grade on Fridays I used to sing in
front of the class pleased to sing over
Frankie Valli songs I would like just
goofing off or or the teacher told me if
she said do you guys if you either could
[ __ ] do this dude I forget the deal
she made I saw every Friday coming with
a jukebox and little record player plug
it in and I put on Frankie Valli my eyes
adored you
Wow and the Michael Jackson songs to her
Lee Michael Jackson [ __ ] I would sing in
front of the class so I had really no
fear of you were nervous at all both of
you guys never cuz to me I would I would
have melted I I didn't like any of that
stuff
no when I was younger I had no I always
kind of got my approval from whether or
not somebody else was paying attention I
don't know like whatever like if people
weren't men I started to feel crappy is
it that makes sense it's the total
opposite right I thought the commie [ __ ]
now I thought about music for a while
maybe play playing an instrument seem
cool but I always liked movies yeah I
always loved all that stuff and I'm like
man I wonder why I could do him there
and then I had listened you know there
wasn't no internet she couldn't read up
on people but I read articles and
different magazines only Oh Who am I
kidding I'm a [ __ ] idiot
I can't throw this [ __ ]
you just didn't know then I'm right
there I'm in the mecca of yeah I mean
now there's a show the or was it the
office that had little Spanish guy on it
yeah Oscar Oscar okay Oscar Nunez has a
brother
and when I was a kid his brother was the
biggest deal in neighborhood now I kept
him well his name is now but he used to
go to he's a mouth and he would go to
the city in the daytime and take
pictures it was a good-looking kid
and then when he come back to Jersey he
would go to a hotdog stand on 30th and
Bergland Avenue which is where the bus
is going to take into the city yeah yeah
and I would see him over there
he had a street name though like a baby
in the Sun he had a street name like
they gave the Cuban that was my first
experience with it but I didn't know you
could take acting lessons and there your
guy had no [ __ ] idea
hmm I had no idea that I even went on
like that and then I had little by
little I saw a soap opera guy once right
and I'm like oh [ __ ] right in Manhattan
I saw like Dex Dexter from from like I
saw Dex Dexter and somebody else from
when the soap operas Dex Dexter was on
dynasty but the other guy was on
something else and I'm like wow these
guys he Michael C Hall I was like Dexter
no not even that no there's a guy named
Dexter okay it was a character named
Dexter Dexter
it couldn't be a cheesier [ __ ] name
and he was on dynasty okay he was
married to the chick on dynasty Lee was
also banging the daughter all right so
that was his name Dex Dexter and then
there was a guy on like we will watch
General Hospital ID and the girl is she
like General Hospital so I won't watch
General Hosking he roped in an aunt and
one day I saw that guy not the singer
Rick Springfield but some other guys in
General Hospital in Manhattan and then
huh pulled it together at that time I
was doing drugs
I mean quaaludes I'm robbing people I'm
like one of my chances of being a
[ __ ] actor so I just abandoned the
[ __ ] toy huh
now how far after you got attacked and
did you get the audition for Blue's
Clues
um not not all that far out of out of a
like I got that job in 2000 and I had
graduated from acting school
1998 so it's like before that you know I
was doing plays and things here and
there you know I got paid to do a couple
of plays I remember I had this him like
I don't know but at the same time I was
on the border just messing it all up I
was eighteen nineteen and just totally
responsible and like to eat it I was the
only one of my family that was doing
anything like that so I had nobody to
kind of ask about what you should do
what you shouldn't do and I was doing
this play at the vineyard theatre and I
remember um is this director was like a
you know who's there's a really amazing
show and I'm still in touch with some of
the people that we did that with we were
all super young and and it was directed
by this guy Michael Mayer who directed
you know angels in America and and and a
bunch of just you know like Spring
Awakening and sideman and you see he was
just a like a Broadway director and he's
directing this off-broadway play and I
was just messing up like I was late all
the time or whatever and he just like I
had to pull me aside and he was like you
know you're about to screw all this up
right and at the time I was like what am
i doing like I don't know I was just so
I was bouncing around just being an
idiot and uh and and yeah and then like
a year a year later essentially is like
when I got that that audition and before
there was like a bunch of commercial
auditions and stuff like that you know
it's like you never you never know
what's gonna land at that point and he's
so young you know it's it's such a crazy
thing well I was just looking looking at
it because I was a little too old even
for the original Blue's Clues but I
remember they were gone but I was
looking I mean it it said that you had
like 15 huh not you but they they went
through like 1500 people to try to find
you like that that's that's a crazy it's
not like there was eight people in the
room it was you went through like a
process yeah well I mean it was a bunch
of different auditions they weren't like
1500 people like it wasn't like American
Idol where they're all spilling right
you know that would be strange but yeah
I had no idea
I actually I don't know it's just it's a
silly story I have a VHS tape of one of
my auditions so the screen test the
final one and I need to get it converted
because nobody has to be a chess player
anymore I need to just like watch it I
need to go back and see it because I'm
convinced that I got that job became
a Christopher Walken impression which is
the stupidest thing so I'm on set and
and and they treated it just like they
were doing the show it's a green screen
studio and it's like at this point it's
down to five guys and um and and so one
of the directors came out and and she
said you know you sound exactly like
Matthew Broderick and you're in this
nervous situation like what do I say and
so my mind starts spinning and spinning
and spinning I don't I don't know what
to do with that information so I just go
back to this thing like making my
buddies like you know laugh or whatever
he says it funny people usually tell me
I sound like Christopher Walken and just
like the crew started chuckling and
Steve did this slow burn of the camera
and he pulled me aside he said okay
so the next time they tell us to go
let's both do walking let's both do it
and I was like you got it man and so we
went out and we didn't tell anybody so
it's like we had to start the scene
again and he's just like hey Joe yes
Steve what are you gonna do today like I
don't know what do you want to do he was
like you want to play Blue's Clues to
figure it out and like it's we sang the
songs like we are gonna play Blue's
Clues
because it's so really yeah oh yeah and
so we just kept going with our silly
Christopher Walken impressions I'm
convinced that that's what got me the
job they said it was some kind of you
know but marketing testing that they
done they put they put like all the
people in front of kids and they
responded me best it was I Oh
Christopher Walken I thank you you
should goes once a week no it would it
would be like six weeks on six weeks off
they would write them and then you know
they go through the storyboarding
process and they make sure that they're
all like around the right time and then
we would do it was a wild thing to do
because Steve had been doing it for
years so is the same crew they all knew
what they were doing and we ran out this
this this green screen or it was blue
screen at first and then later on when
they changed the colors of my shirt it
became like a green screen or a blue
screen dependent on what I was wearing
and um we would do shoot for about six
weeks we get like five six episodes done
but I'm the only actor on set there was
nobody else there it was me and then
they would have one actor both times it
was this woman that like
from women named Katie so like they
would do all the other voices they were
like just off the camera so we get all
the timing down and I would show up at
like 7:00 a.m. and I'd leave at about
7:00 p.m. at some point and we would
shoot like I don't know 10 out of 12 of
those hours it was just like a crazy
process because it's like I would go and
then all right they'd be ready and
they'd moved the camera and you know
just like whenever I could go again and
then we go and you know how would you
behave you out of that show once you got
on there I had to learn to grow up I had
to learn that's where I actually learned
how to be responsible because that some
point it was like I realized it wasn't
just me when I was the only guy you know
you show up late nobody can work like
nobody can do anything and so that's
when I figured out essentially how to be
a professional you know it took me a
while
I almost said I don't pick things up
quickly it takes me a minute but it take
took me and [ __ ] well too
you have to see it yeah you have to see
how people act like I was given the
worst advice like a dear friend of mine
came up to me and said listen to all
these meetings you don't want after this
movie be there late make them weekly hmm
that's how you become a star and I
actually believed it I was late for like
four meetings and only something isn't
right it's not it's against what [ __ ] I
am right what did that person do for a
living did would you comedians comedian
so he wanted you to do to to develop
some kind of air of a story or whatever
it is like you know I didn't like it
yeah I don't get that part of it and he
failed with it so right it was he failed
miserably with it he failed miserably
with the end of his career in many ways
hmm because of his arrogance towards
people and I didn't like it you know I
didn't like it at all I mean I saw it I
see it over he is like I was just a
distress factory and this disturbed me I
I saw that this comic was there and I go
how was it they were like it's [ __ ]
uh I could bothers you that this guy
acts this way really like you're not in
the room hmm
like he's very nice he'll come over say
I am taught that the Holliman hi I'm
done at that and then that's it doesn't
talk to the staff doesn't want the staff
to come into the green room isn't hungry
there's no anything to drink do not
bother me you know you know it's just
and you come in you get him he goes up
he does his time he goes off no pictures
no nothing really
yeah doesn't want to be bothered doesn't
want to they believe in green room is
what he's saying that brilliant to where
it like you have them whatever their
goal not at all yeah that's right yeah
so the arrogance that every level
bothers the [ __ ] out of a guy like me
because you know you put your pants on
one leg at a time
yeah look bothers the [ __ ] out of me you
know I used to think that about like the
Queen of England I was like at some
point she's got to take a dump in that
dress yeah it's all just people which is
[ __ ] people we as people sometimes
blame that kind of caste system on our
failure but there's no real caste system
not we're all the same and we all get
the same opportunities it's what the
[ __ ] you want to do it but totally or if
you pick up the ball and run with it
well isn't it kind of like what you
would be what you allow because we I've
been in situations where people late and
just me naturally I'm a reserved and shy
person so I don't say anything I think
there's some people who maybe joy maybe
someone else who let's say someone was
late or someone talk [ __ ] to them on a
set and if you check them a little bit
maybe they they won't act that way with
you anymore because they don't act that
way with everybody I mean they probably
are nice to their friends but it's just
what you allow people to do like
empowers and somebody check you out
doing get angry at them for a few days
until you realize they were really
helping you out oh yes I am that that
guy that way you got through you to play
and he pulled you see yeah and he said
what are you doing here you know at
first you walk away thinking this
[ __ ] jerk-off haha but if you have
any brain
as a man and if your ego allows it you
like that person just saved my [ __ ]
life if I had any brains I would have
done it then it wouldn't it take yeah
it's [ __ ] terrible what we put
ourselves through well nothing happens
on your own like III my thought of it
now is that is that you do whatever you
can do and at some point somebody else
in your life is gonna take a chance on
you someone else in your life is gonna
give you an opportunity and then your
job like a lot of times as an actor but
almost as anything is to make whoever
put you in that room look good look good
whoever took you that chance I have to
make him look good absence so it's it
all goes together I don't forget I
worked my brother in law for a while he
was sweet enough to give me a roofing
job as a laborer and when I saw my
cheque the first time I almost died I
couldn't believe what he was paying he
was paying me thousands to do labor his
job like that at that age of 30 whatever
I was 29 I decided then I'm not gonna be
like every other brother-in-law I swear
to god I was like I gotta be the
worthless brother-in-law that job
started at 8:00 I was there except I
made myself be there at 7:00 even though
her buddy else got there at 8:00 I got
there it's out and then do a lot of work
between 7:00 but I was there with him
carry the stuff and load along yeah and
I would leave last and I would do double
the work of everybody else or exactly or
more than what they did just because I
was the brother alone I didn't want to
make him look bad so way before I got
into comedy I already knew the need to
make people recommend you good because
these people gonna keep suggesting you
for [ __ ] yeah they keep suggesting if
this [ __ ] number two would calm me
there's a guy named Matt woods and he
saved my comedy career by having a long
talk with me that was very short and
very like it was one of the best talks I
ever got so this day you know I send him
my love last year he was in New Mexico
but that guy had a heart-to-heart with
me that just sliced me and a half about
stand-up
yeah like if you're gonna do it do it
type of deal right huh just go back to
selling drugs like he was dead serious
sure he's like the [ __ ] you could do
yeah but you want to [ __ ] around you
want to show up with a t-shirt and you
don't want to write jokes yeah you wanna
cancel gigs he goes I can't even imagine
and today everything he said was right
hmm that's how much the guy knew his
[ __ ]
he's like when you put your head to this
it's gonna be [ __ ] awful people have
a hard time with you and he was like
straight up like I've been doing this
for 20 years and I know when I say it
you got it you just don't want to put no
effort into it because you're scared of
what the result might be hmm and that's
fine he's like you could be a [ __ ] all
your life that's how you have to talk to
people want you or turn around and walk
away
and they'll complain to their friends
and they'll go on Facebook
somebody insulted me deeply this evening
yeah
men and their ego is checked they'll go
oh my god he was right well yeah he said
that type of [ __ ] all the time like I'm
you're too scared to see what the result
might be if your [ __ ] just like the
song joong hangover to started crying
instantly oh yeah absolutely right when
people talk to you like that and and
people we will quit we'll never go back
yeah because they'll never want to be
put in that situation and that's too
close to home to a parent it's too close
it's even tougher than a parent it'sit's
that football coach it's that yeah like
I've never I never want somebody ever
talking but the last person that talked
of me was broken and I don't like it
nobody should have to have a talk with
you about what's going on genomes and
and those people they usually have to
talk me you really love you to death
yeah they really they're the ones that
actually care yeah they really care
about you and it takes them a lot like
you've you stuck a [ __ ] nerve when
their lives like when Rogen sat me down
that plant I had nowhere to go
yeah like I had nowhere to go I had to
hear this out
and I didn't talk to her for a while I
made the point Eddie Bravo was the one
that said dog what's wrong with you talk
alright he's heartbroken he didn't say
that bad he was right
everything he said was came out to the
weather hmm well how do I mean how do
you guys do that talk with people now
how do you choose because you can look
at people around you and you see ten
thousand people a day doing things wrong
or ways that you don't think they should
do it how do you make the decision to
like to have that time with someone I
don't feel like I know enough to give
anybody that talk right now I feel like
I'm still learning in some ways you know
that's I mean like going back to like
what's difficult about parenting or
there's like I don't believe half the
stuff that comes out of my face
sometimes I'm but even even like
somebody's gonna call me on it even if
you want a set and so 23 year old
version of you you you lug you wouldn't
feel the urge to but right away I have
to get to know that person yeah I have
to get to love them and know they should
I want to say to people I just careful
but this comments that I care about I
want to go ahead man knock it off with
that I like the heart to do that but
somebody that I really really really
really really care about and then go in
a good direction [ __ ] yeah tell them
Twitter man you're doing this it's all
good but you can't keep doing this
you're just killing yourself to live how
do I know I did it you just [ __ ] it's
a tire and mud that's all you're doing
yeah yeah if I'm somebody like it just
destroying their own future it's it's
not a matter get you get out of that mud
well what the [ __ ] do you know I was in
the mud for [ __ ] 15 12 years I know
how to get stopped right now to get out
yeah I know I just get stuck in that mud
for [ __ ] years I could do it again
you want to see do you guys ever feel
yourself reverting back to where you
were like maybe maybe making a bad
decision being late one time like do you
guys ever one like check yourself a
little bit
why you still yeah I mean I don't know
you seem like you probably are late for
anything
you know what just gotta be I gotta get
there early yeah I get that you know
somebody call if I call you and I go hey
I had a TV show for you it's an ABC show
yeah okay the call time is 8:00
I expect you at 7:30 John because you're
professional you know there's gonna be
but even if I go to CBS Radford going in
an 8 o'clock you know it takes you 20
minutes to park 20 minutes the park and
see me why what's it gonna take you at
Fox awful [ __ ] what's that oh yeah in
Culver City because they don't let you
in Pico no more oh you gotta go knock
down all the stars and go down three
lights and then make a left aren't kind
of shitty dead-end street they get the
Fox and you gotta go and then you can
see the line like people the left-hand
Lane is packed
yeah they got nowhere to go oh it's just
one Street it's just all the roads lead
to Fox yeah it's [ __ ] crazy so you
have to be there and even I gotta go
Park on like the fifth or fourth or
something like that you gotta go way up
yeah yeah you got a part in the other
part close to the elevator cuz you plan
on walking Jack all those auditions you
get there you like where is it they're
like okay you see that Street yeah go
all the way to the end then make it a
left and go like that and then the maker
you like what and then have like two
blocks the sun's burning on you you see
one of those carts one of those guys oh
sure he like dog do you know what come
on up and I'll give you a ride oh thank
[ __ ] god well if you're in a studio
like that I always feel like I'm gonna
get lost and then oh no you once you be
if you don't know where you are it takes
forever ever they're so big I worked on
a show on Sunset and Gower and it's a
studio and they have like weird little
streets and houses I got lost like I
work nights I work out at 3 in the
morning I was walking through the back
of things someone had to finally come
and rescue me I didn't know I had it
scary [ __ ] scary [ __ ] we have some
shout out to you yep no it's great to
get you on just to talk from that
perspective
steelg Templar I love you the caelius
Adam appleís you bad [ __ ] he's
on Facebook Rock
the game J everyday Don Wrangler oten
meltdown Brandi Lynn Gibbons don't
forget keep donating she's making things
happen Lauren Rosen cook I love you
buddy hope you're doing well or forget
I'm at the Colusa casino on the 16th and
don't forget Eddie Bravo and Sam Tripoli
or at Cobbs this Friday night if you're
up in San Francisco go get ready some
[ __ ] conspiracy theories gonna talk
about ghosts whatever the [ __ ] you ain't
it
are they going on the Sacramento the
next I think maybe think so do well
let's get him up the cops for right now
and we'll give them with the Sacramento
by that time sacrament the sacrament was
a smaller place does he spend the arm
bar people if they're like if he has
like Chuck people I know it would be
nice to like have that like go tour with
addy because if anyone's gonna start
shitty like you know Eddie Bravo's here
got a handle it was actually pretty fun
we did a class yesterday at a jujitsu
place and I was joking with the coach
because right above his security sticker
like this place is secured it's just a
picture of his jujitsu logo and he says
no one messes but yeah one beat one time
one someone came in to steal something
and they loved in other people doing
jiu-jitsu they ran away be awful just
breaking into a house that random and
you find out it's like it's like the
sheriff of whatever town he's just
sitting there cleaning a gun but that
would be horrible what's he gonna steal
from a dojo or either you know like a
sweaty mat like what are you gonna steal
you never know what's yeah you know the
guy might have his mortgage payment
living last lease rent on Starbucks to
get coffee yeah and you walk in and
there is number Joy's the guy that drove
us to New York but yeah absolutely
George is a dear dear friend of mine I
love with all my heart
in 1993 I'm living in bold I'm not going
anywhere like I'm just in a [ __ ] pun
moved back and I stayed with Mike Ronnie
for like a month until his wife has the
baby and when she has the baby I have to
move him with George but George it's
heroin hmm that kid that drove us over
was a [ __ ] nutcase cryin was just bad
so uh how do you get out of that oh my
god so uh he's on heroin and it's a
Sunday I'll never forget this and I had
this little college girlfriend I was
datin I have been messing around with
her in Boulder for about a year and now
she was living on by the FOB by
Manhattan Honda okay on 18 whatever that
you're like all the way on the west side
yeah the West yeah she had a little bit
on the corner was Goodfellas pizza and
there was a wild bar on that like 15th
Street that was a wild bar they do
comedy there
oh is that coyote ugly no no no no this
little thing I bought houses and I'll
never forget being in there and there
was a black chick at the bar like I had
a couple of great times in there huh
yeah well in there with a friend of mine
one night we bumped into two chicks to
do open mic and next thing on my buddy
had the girl onstage with no shirt on
what and we'll make what suck in the
titties it's [ __ ] crazy
it's good this bar was crazy it was a
dirty open mic like Tuesdays and
Wednesdays from 9:00 to 11:00 I was just
getting into comedy so to make a long
story short there's one Sunday I'm bored
to pieces I got 26 bucks I got a spot in
the city and I can't go over now to get
weed because I can't afford to go over
and back yeah you never saying like yes
I went to the city I got to go into the
city I gotta wait till five or six
before I go into the city in those days
I was walking over you walk over the
George Washington Bridge oh I would walk
from Cliffside Park and then with
terrace oh my that's actually all the
way the Fort Lee stop and get a bagel
when they had the fresh bagels right by
the bridge yeah I get a poppy seed with
a [ __ ] nobody who worked at that
store that [ __ ] Square Fort Lee diner
is right then I walk over that [ __ ]
George Washington Bridge and if I was
being really really it was a Safeway
there like a supermarket there
read something like go in there and
steal like either tampons or a box of
[ __ ] yeast medication I'm walking
over you walk it over the George
Washington Bridge and you find the boat
day got 181st reading they would buy
yeast medication from the aspirin
because all the girls are - you would so
that's something I never ever thought my
black market yeah our black market
fabric and it would be like the small
pointy dude we were at we were a store
last night that a store that just had a
bunch of stuff that was out it was just
like I thought they were gonna put it
away or something but it like Joey was
looking at looking at me like if this
was 20 years ago
oh yeah this is Jack Daniels just on the
street 12 bottles of peace xx bottle
fell under the case I get a liquor store
there were six cases 1204 six cases give
me 1,100 cash I'll be out of your life
forever gonna take it you knows I mean
that's how he lived
plus they had ten cases of you plus a
case of Malibu rum and so 1213 allow the
score and the whole day's real quick
real quick just go get the clock go get
the car you know we were parked where
we're we were parked last night I had to
drive it over to the gate like we own
the joint and I why were you gonna get
the car I'm bringing cases back then I
just blow them up and by the time you
back up there's already four cases back
is loading them in like you own the
place you can't do that now cuz this
canvas right they got you I'll have to
disconnect to 80 82 [ __ ] canvas I
know that type of type or where I'm
gonna ask or something but then you're
the dude wearing a mask and everybody
knows where you know they look so unless
you want to wear a mask all it's a
Sunday it's a Sunday it's a beautiful
day
I'll never [ __ ] forget this I'm since
George is already heroin that it's gotta
be one or two in the after little in
George's already on arrow he's going in
and out of this heroin and there was a
lady right above us and she's in the
backyard cooking hamburgers with like a
[ __ ] younger boyfriend giggling and
she had like a kid that wasn't her
husband that wasn't the kid's father but
I'm watching this and I go she's
downstairs where's her purse
huh okay I went out the front door I run
up to her apartment cuz you live right
over us and that went for the door
and sure enough it's open I knock first
nobody said hello and and she's in the
backyard cooking a boy for his lane to
have one of those [ __ ] Guido things
but never reflect yeah there was a
reflection and I'm like these [ __ ]
dummies and sure enough a purse is on
the dinner table right when I walk in
with a deposit slip with no deposit and
lower like she just cast a check oh man
I just took the whole thing they had to
be in her house and I wasn't downstairs
you know me though I'm a little slide
dog I'm a degenerate
look you have a spider-man sense but
it's receiving things yeah it should be
it was terrible I always walked in at
the right place and I went downstairs
and I hid the money and I laid back on
the couch like nothing happened and I
watched him eat the burger and the whole
[ __ ] floor oh my god that going if I
leave George is gonna know I robbed yeah
yeah yeah I cannot leave this lady's
gonna say something sure enough the
barbecue ends then I'll update ten
minutes she's not on the door with the
cops and and she's like looking for
George
the whole building no he was a junkie
right right like Where's George enjoy
just [ __ ] Lee what and she goes you
robbed my money everybody knows you're
in junkies ik huh I haven't left the bed
I sleep with all day and she goes you
can even ask Oakland I'm like he's been
there all day and she goes who II don't
like I've been here with him I haven't
left me this goes well somebody went
into my apartment and took my paycheck
and I'm [ __ ] Howard Howard inside I'm
dying the laughter cuz she doesn't even
think about me she's just blaming George
I'm surprised you didn't go down and be
like oh you're cooking have a burger and
then you like share a burger whether
well just know you know I wouldn't I
wouldn't have the guts that could be
this is law this is well that was crazy
the cops couldn't press charges on
either of us even George so if you want
look around I have no money I got the
$19 I took my pie like $26 I'm waiting
but they understand that downstairs in
the basement in the garbage hidden and
God wants the cop stuff we were back for
the background and George goes I know
you
I go I'll give you a hundred someone
does des I gave me yardstick and I shout
out with to the city with seven bills
and put a bow wow I got a hotel room in
this city she came over like a doctor
you know me I my scam was all right
this is scam this is ridiculous
I wasn't like sneak out of the house in
junior high or something like that in
Vegas and my buddy Matt and I and my
brother sometimes we'd go down to the
7-eleven and I take two packs of bubble
Isha's and I'd pretend like I was
looking in my pocket for money and then
I come back out with one that was my
move that's the move
that's I was I thought I was like the
world's best criminal take two lighters
right in front of the [ __ ] 7-eleven
when you get for the cigarettes you have
some four cigarettes he turns around
when he turns back around you're pulling
out a wallet right he's looking at you
like but he don't have the balls to ask
you what's in your pocket he knows you
shoplift it but he can't ask you you
won't follow my wallet I shoplift it a
few times but not because they used to
there's a store called strawberries
yeah it's growing out from using plain
clothes and stuff and they had the of
court and that's closed now they had
instead of gift cards they had like
coins that were worth ascending the
mountain when I took one once because it
was a good the worst system everybody
they had to activate it or anything I
need that I oh this isn't really
stealing but in college I figured out
that this place had a coupon and if you
spent like eight bucks you got a free
mini pizza so or whatever was I got I
did it so many times they they call him
and said you're gonna have to order more
or we're not coming over there it's like
I remember oh man this takes me back a
little bit I was I forget how old I was
I must have been six or seven it was
right after soccer practice because I
like soccer shorts on or it was a game
and I had my cleats and stuff sometimes
when you'd walk around the grocery store
with cleats and I remember putting a box
of Tic Tacs
in my pocket the bug was gonna steal it
and we're out in the parking lot and my
mom could hear me because it's tic tacs
that go on there and she's turns around
like you have to take what did you
steal those like you know see totally I
got totally busted and she made me go
back and give her back and apologize to
the cashier it was like that whole man
I'm surprised I ever stole anything
again it was I was so like mortified it
was a shadow of such what it's a
stupidest thing ever egde I was scared
the [ __ ] steel for that I tried it
one time I loved it
once I stole I got away with that I
loved it the rushes of high [ __ ] that
gift card was amazing and I I tamed it
down for years and then once I became a
burglar once you walk on lash you might
as well [ __ ] dance I'm saying yeah we
live in tight dilemmas tonight being a
pet I think about that all the time
and you do too I know you have a
daughter and a son I just have a
daughter and I'm like what the [ __ ] am I
gonna tell her
she's not gonna see these stories she's
lying I write her I write a journal for
okay which is slowly getting to the
point you know saying it's like in three
chapters out right now like every three
days every four days what she's going
through what I'm going through
just a slow her in a little bit yeah and
she can't she's not from the cut that
she could get all this she doesn't she
doesn't see it that way it's so weird
how different we are at the age of five
at the 85 I had already been involved in
like a [ __ ] drug bust
Thompson CDs were fine I was already
involved in the drug bust
well what are you selling a records only
nothing I was at a [ __ ] house that
got me there okay okay you know to see a
raid mm when you're at five other
numbers joy and then they raid your
mother's place it gives you doubts
you're at school talking to officer
Rocco the dead cop often llaves around
it's weird that talked to officer rocky
when your mother just got [ __ ]
arrested the booklet right I can't
imagine yeah think about that secret
that you're hiding is all right mercy
doesn't have that [ __ ] I shouldn't have
that at all so in five she didn't have a
fight I didn't have a father at five so
she's way ahead of me at five way ahead
like I wasn't even talking with five I
was just waiting to cry do you have a
plan with this like when she gets 10 12
what what are you gonna give it to her
well did my gonna give it to him I'm
gonna see how she takes to what's going
on around them
there's no age okay so there's no plane
there's no ways she have to see if she's
ready you know when I see people when I
go up to you my way men got kids and
you're like how old is your daughter you
know and you're like 16 I always look at
that kid hmm and go could they handle
finding Donovan on the floor when she
was 16 like I found my mother I had know
how many people I couldn't know those
kids can bounce back from that you never
know what you're ready for until it
happens and how you gonna respond to it
you know I just saw a dear friend of
mine a couple weekends ago she's never
been the same since her father died I
get that she was very tight with her
death it takes she is a reconciliation
and you no doubt when you're a son and
your parents die that's a completely
different chapter of your life well we
mentioned it look they're not gonna both
my parents are still here
but what do you think when you when you
saw that 30 year old kid who had to get
taken to court to get thrown out of his
parents house as parents what do you
like what mistakes do you think they
make like what like how does that happen
they didn't they didn't get it what's
this they should have stopped Hitler in
Munich that line resonates in my head
fills everything now yeah if you're if
you're a [ __ ] business owner I like
I'm in here late three times you gonna
pull me aside when they go and yeah we
gotta stop Hitler in Munich because if
he does this every day and then it's
gonna become a problem and that's where
we slept like we don't remember that the
simple fact yeah you gotta try there's
something that rattles around my brain
every now and again where it's like I'm
sitting there and I'll be talking to my
daughter
and I don't know if she's just waiting
for me to be done you know what I mean
she's like just waiting it out like at
some point he's gonna stop talking
cuz every now and again I'll I'll get
twisted around in my sentence and I'll
try to essentially not curse when I'm
talking to her you know it's like
because I'll be worked up about
something like she's either done or and
my whole thing is is not so much about
uh it's about intention you know I say
it's it's not a you know you could
succeed or fail like you know some
things happen some things don't happen
but but if you don't try that's the big
problem and so it's just a matter of
like where you what you're going for
like everybody deserves respect and if
you're gonna do something like you know
I I just don't want it I don't want to
hear like I don't want to or I don't
like that like if I don't even try it
you know I don't I don't know if my I
got a little sidetracked in my point
there but but sometimes when I'm talking
to her I don't know if she's just like
like mm-hmm
I get to go back to my Barbie in like
two minutes come on every season because
we can try and who knows like if they're
actually gonna listen to our lesson if
they're gonna want to rebel against that
or if they're gonna just essentially
emulate what we do instead of what we
say one way or another I mean I don't
know it's such a crazy mixed bag
we just don't know we're all fumbling in
the dark it's crazy that's the scary
we're not gonna know all you can do is
try yeah that's what I do with mercy all
I could do is try you know when I saw
you do the Christopher Walken I forgot
you're a great [ __ ] voiceover yeah
yeah one team umizoomi for a few years
you well you've done a lot of video
games - yeah yeah I don't well I've done
a few like a lot of who's a did motion
capture for grand theft auto 5 which was
really funny just like you got the suit
on and you're running around is like me
and this this actor Brad Schmidt and a
stuntman in Chris place I mean it was
like the three of us just taking turns
doing random stuff like you know like
carjacking ever done or being considered
to do like after Blue's Clues it was
that was a strange like one of the next
jobs have you play one of the main
people or they just had you know it's
the in-game motion capture so it's like
it's like the the character as when
you're running around and he's not the
cutscenes but I did a few things with
those guys um and they were awesome
actually that was amazing watching them
like Stephen hog and got him solo I have
no idea what his real name is but
everybody called him solo on set and I
never bothered to find out his real name
okay he's got a real name sometimes you
don't need to look day
Donovan I'm happy you made it on time
I'm happy to be here man great things go
on you know you're real close to us you
can come on whenever you want hopefully
you'll get an Instagram page now I did I
finally started I instagrammed Twitter
just for this occasion and I have no
idea what I'm gonna do with it
don't do nothing every day put something
on that little pictures let people know
what the [ __ ] you're doing you know
you're an interesting cat that's why I
wanted to have you he's been coming to
the fourth wall he's been coming to
finally did stand up a little stand up
which is always gets a respect not out
of my [ __ ] because I know how hard it
is to actually say you're gonna go down
there and then go down and get on stage
like it's it's you jumping off the cliff
Oh without jumping in I'm saying yeah
and I'm just glad that I couldn't hear
my own like a heartbeat and that was the
only sound in the room it was not the
worst thing ever and I actually
videotaped myself so I saw it and then I
realized there's like like just on the
first pass I was like there's 16
different ways where I could have been
better just even with that and it's like
I I feel like a fraud when I'm up there
like is that I don't feel like a fraud I
was talking about that just a couple
minutes ago I have full knowledge that I
don't know what I'm doing
and I want to be good at it like when I
want you do it you get that like that I
don't know it satisfies that wanting to
perform I love that feeling and so I
want to be good at this thing but
nothing happens like that no you know
you got him you know I've been doing it
27 years and I feel like a [ __ ] fraud
yeah and I'm taping a thing on Monday
for Netflix and I have no idea where I'm
at no but I know I like time because I
practice what I preach when you commit
to the universe it tastes great yeah
I've done everything I can my part
something will happen
I'll make something happen I'm that
confident so that's it I'll see you next
time I'm gonna get the [ __ ] out of here
next time we talk [ __ ] I just
have just so shooting especially Netflix
hopefully I'll be shooting but I want to
thank you guys for busting Netflix's
balls and them
and all the support in love you guys
give us over the years the church Scott
Cunningham with the page I love you to
death I can't wait to finally meet you
when you come out and that's it that's
how easy this is it's been an easy
[ __ ] week I want to thank Donovan
Patton again watching my Blue's Clues
our team will resume me or any other
[ __ ] other stuff he's done you can
IMDB em the flying jew is coming to
Vegas
Danny Browns come to Vegas we're gonna
see who you spooky in Las Vegas we're
gonna see a lot of people miles make us
I'm looking forward to it
but I want to thank you guys because
without you guys I'd have blue gots a
nap dick so thank you again for your
support and love and we'll see you next
week what before you leave we got to
talk to you about something
like I told you earlier all right 66% of
men lose their head by 35 it's that
hairline slowly starting to move
backwards any bald spots yet me I answer
both I answer yes to both of them how
will you feel year from now when it's
business as usual up there I ask you do
two things do you want a bald spot to
pop up or do you want something do you
want to do something about it first do
you want your hairline to recede or you
want to do something about it first
why do guys turn to weird solutions when
they can turn to medicine and science
okay what will it do for you we'll
introduce you to four hemes calm a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness for men thanks to
science baldness can be optional him
connects you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat your
hair loss well known generic equivalents
to name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair no snake oil pills no gas
station supplements prescription
solutions backed by science and it's
easy there's no waiting room there's no
awkward doctor visits and you save hours
by going to floor hems
dot-com that's it that's how easy it is
answer a few quick questions the doctor
review it and they'll prescribe you a
product that gets shipped directly to
your door okay like I said I got a
better sitting headline now I'm losing
my hair but it served this purpose
but I know what it's like because I saw
what it did to a friend of mine don't
let this happen to you what I'm gonna do
is now order now today the church family
gets a trial month two hymns for five
hours today right now while supplies
last go to the website first go to for
hymns calm and for the questionnaire
you're gonna love it
alright see the website for full details
this would cost you hundreds if you went
to a doctor or pharmacy what I'm gonna
do for you is go to for hymns calm slash
Joey again fr hims dot-com slash Joey
for for hims dot-com slash Joey listen
you'll be happy you went there whether
it's sexual wellness the hair loss or
the skin care we got your covered I wish
I was around when I was losing my hair
that's right
that's for hymns calm slash Joey number
to me undies is the best pair underwears
out there again you know for years
you've been here me and talk about me on
these half years of ordered it me on
these special and it's different from
any other underwear because then may
with a sustainability source material
from Beach with trees then naturally saw
fiber makes the fabric that won't sag
down or won't ride up trust me once you
put a pair on you're gonna love them
alright me I've been hooked on me on
these four years whether it's underwear
the socks I love everything they do they
sent me sure I mean they are a
phenomenal company now me undies are so
sure you'll love the first pair but if
you're not happy they'll do whatever
they can debt to get into you get you
the right pair that you'll love and if
they can't keep them and they'll refund
your money it's that easy it's a wrist
it's free to try the best underwear ever
ask yourself that question and if you're
already partnering me on these family
tell your friends about it through their
referral program they'll get a discount
and you'll get store credit so it's a
win-win situation all right listen do me
a favor
you know I love your [ __ ] to
death go to me on these calm right now
take a look around first time purchase
get 20% off their first pair on me
undies and free shipping [ __ ] that's
20% off and free shipping and again
t-that me undies will make you [ __ ]
happy and you'll be satisfied get your
butt over to me on these calm right now
and treat yourself okay to get 20% off
your first pair with free shipping and
satisfaction guarantee go to me on these
coms last Joey again that's me on these
dot-com / Joey I want to thank my man
Donovan I want to thank my man - flying
Jew and you [ __ ] for a great
week again we'll talk next week thank
you for everything you've done i'ma
leave you with some Kenny Rogers you
picked a fine time to leave me Lucille
kick that [ __ ] meal leave thank you
very much have a great week
[Music]